tenemos aquí una simulación que fue
creada por peter calling reach
usando el bloc de notas para ciencias de
la computación de khan academy y esta
simulación fue hecha para que entendamos
mejor por qué dividimos entre n menos 1
cuando estamos tratando de calcular la
varianza muestral in sesgada porque
cuando estamos tratando de estimar sin
sesgo cuál es la verdadera varianza de
la población así es que esta simulación
lo que hace es primero construir una
distribución de población y es una
distribución aleatoria lo que hay cada
vez que obtengas una de estas va a ser
una distribución de población diferente
esta en particular tiene una población
de 383 y después directamente a partir
de cada distribución de población
calcula los parámetros por ejemplo esta
tiene una media de 10.9 y una varianza
de 25.5
después utiliza esa misma población para
sacar muestras porque yo saca muchas
muestras de tamaño 2 3 4 5 hasta de
tamaño 10 y sigue sacando muestras de
ella y también calcula las estadísticas
para todas esas muestras o sea calcula
las medias muestrales sesgadas y todo
eso nos dice un montón de cosas y nos
ayuda a tener un poco más de intuición y
bueno uno le puede hacer clic a cada una
de estas gráficas y hacer un
acercamiento para poder realmente
estudiar con mucho detalle cada una de
estas gráficas yo ya les saque una foto
a cada una y las puse en mi blog de
dibujos para que podamos realmente
profundizar en la matemática y la
intuición que nos están enseñando estas
gráficas así es que tenemos aquí una
captura de la pantalla y podemos ver que
en este caso el tamaño de la población
es de 529
media 10.6
y podemos ver por aquí por aquí que
tenemos gráfica da la media de la
población que es 10.6 con esta línea
punteada
y también tenemos que la varianza de
esta población es 36.8 nos regresamos
por aquí y también tenemos aquí gráfica
da la varianza de la población que es
36.8 y esta gráfica de aquí abajo a la
izquierda de hecho nos está diciendo
bastantes cosas claro que hay algo en lo
que quiero hacer hincapié y es el hecho
de que esta es la varianza muestral
sesgada y en esta otra gráfica también
estamos hablando de la varianza muestral
sesgada sesgada así es que está
calculando esto
para cada una de nuestras muestras así
es que para cada uno de los datos de
nuestra muestra desde el primer dato
hasta el último dato vamos a tomar ese
dato le vamos a restar la media muestral
vamos a elevar esta diferencia al
cuadrado y después dividiendo todo esto
no entre en menos uno sino entre n y
esto de aquí de hecho nos muestra cosas
muy interesantes por ejemplo podemos
observar que aquellos casos donde
subestimamos la varianza donde la
varianza de la muestra es muy baja
por ejemplo en estos casos y estos otros
casos de aquí donde la varianza de la
muestra está muy cerca de cero para la
mayoría de esos casos su media muestral
está bastante lejos de la verdadera
media de la población aunque también lo
podemos ver al revés
si la media de la muestra está muy
alejada de la verdadera media de la
población es bastante más probable que
la varianza de esa muestra esté
subestimando a la verdadera varianza de
la población ahora otra cosa a la que le
tenemos que poner atención es que entre
más chico sea el tamaño de la muestra
más rosa va a ser el punto que la
representa y lo mismo entre más grande
sea el tamaño de la muestra más azul va
a ser el punto que la representa y
podemos ver por aquí en estas dos colas
hay muchos más puntitos rosas mientras
que la mayoría de los puntos azules se
encuentran por acá y nos están dando
mejores estimaciones de la media y la
varianza de la población es cierto
también hay algunos puntos rosas por acá
que hace que esto se vea como que más
morado y que también de repente por acá
podemos encontrar alguna
puntos azules de pura casualidad pero
por aquí en las colas básicamente
tenemos puros puntitos rosas lo cual
tiene mucho sentido porque si el tamaño
de tu muestra es muy pequeño es muy
probable que obtengas una media muestral
que no sea una buena estimación de la
media de la población porque es más
probable que la media de tu muestra
quede lejos de la media de la población
y lo mismo sucede con la varianza de la
muestra es más probable que la varianza
muestral sea un estimador que estés
subestimando por mucho la varianza de la
población ahora esta gráfica de aquí
realmente nos lleva al meollo del asunto
porque porque para cada uno de estos
tamaños de muestra vamos a empezar con
el tamaño de muestra 2 calcula la
varianza muestral sesgada entre la
varianza de la población pero
de muchísimas muchísimas muestras de
tamaño 2 que nos siguen saliendo y nos
siguen saliendo muestras de tamaño 2
sacamos la varianza muestral sesgada la
dividimos entre la varianza real de la
población sacamos la media de todos esos
porcentajes que nos dio y aquí esta
gráfica nos dice que esa media es justo
50% aquello es justo un medio de la
verdadera varianza de la población y
luego para el tamaño de muestra 3
hacemos lo mismo y nos queda dos
terceras partes de la varianza real de
la población porque nos queda 66.666 66
por ciento de la verdadera varianza de
la población y cuando el tamaño de la
muestra es 4 nos acercamos a tres
cuartas partes de la verdad de la
varianza de la población si es que se
nos puede ocurrir más o menos una idea
de qué es lo que está sucediendo en el
fondo
utilizamos el estimador sesgado en
realidad no nos estamos acercando a la
varianza de la población más bien nos
estamos acercando a n
1 / n por la varianza de la población
cuando n es 2
aquí tenemos un medio de la varianza de
la población por un medio de la varianza
de la población cuando en estrés tenemos
dos tercios de la varianza de la
población cuando n es cuatro tenemos
tres cuartos de la varianza de la
población y así nos podemos seguir así
es que esto nos está dando un estimador
sesgado y como le vamos a hacer para
quitarle el sesgo bueno pues si
realmente queremos obtener el mejor
estimador de la verdadera varianza de la
población en lugar de obtener n menos
uno entre n por la varianza de la
población pues queremos multiplicar por
n entre n menos 1
queremos multiplicar por n / n 1 y
estamos multiplicando por esto para
obtener un estimador yn sesgado que
entonces n menos uno se cancela con n
menos uno n se cancela con n y nos queda
la varianza de la población que es justo
lo que queremos estimar ahora de este
lado n se cancela con n y nos queda el
estimador integrado de la varianza de la
población o sea la varianza muestral en
sesgada que es igual y esto es lo que
hemos visto en los últimos vídeos y lo
que te vas a encontrar en los libros a
algunas veces es confuso el porqué pero
con un poco de suerte esta simulación de
peter te ayuda a entender por qué si
tiene que ser este el estimador de la
varianza en sesgado
aquí queremos dividir entre n menos uno
por gay